Oh, okay-- so, did you guys
see what Trump's spokesman said
on CNN yesterday?
Oh... oh, my God,
this was unbelievable.
I thought I had seen it all
in their... in their, like,
non-answering
of-of questions, right?
-You know, um...
-(cheering, applause)
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
-Hey! What are you doing?
-Nothing.
-What are you doing? -I...
-You took...
-I was gonna take some stuff.
-You're taking my (bleep)?
-All right.
Jon... It's Jon Stewart.
How you doing, man?
How you doing?
-(cheering, applause continuing)
-Good to see you.
-Jon Stewart, everybody.
-Hey, buddy.
-Have a seat.
-What did I miss?
-You, uh, you missed
a lot, man. -What did I miss?
-What's going on?
-Uh...
-What are we doing next week?
-It's, uh, you know,
-i-it's the last show. I'm
trying to do... -The last show?
-Yes, the last show. -Oh, my
God, what, did you piss off
Peter Thiel?
What happened?
Is that... Did he... Is his...
Does revenge no know bounds?
-No, it knows no bounds, Jon.
-It knows no bounds.
-No bounds. -Uh, I-I just-I just
decided to stop by...
-Oh, cool.
-and tell you I love you.
-Oh. -And I-I...
-AUDIENCE: Aw.
And may I say something else?
If-if I may?
-Sure. You... No, you may.
-Do you have I moment?
-Take the moment.
-Thank you. Uh...
Jon Stewart, everyone.
-(cheering, applause)
-No, I just want to say...
-No, very quickly...
-Mm-hmm? Yeah.
Uh, I have been
in situations in, uh,
what we call show business,
television, where they have,
-uh, my name has been
on the show. -Yes.
And they've, uh,
what-what do you call their...
-locked the door...
-Yes.
and-and told me to, uh...
uh, this was
a Paramount executive:
"Get your (bleep) and get out."
-Right. -And, uh,
a very wise man said to me...
-Mm-hmm. -uh,
do not confuse
cancellation with failure.
-And I took that to heart.
-(cheering, applause)
Yeah.
So, I will say this:
what you, my friend,
were tasked to do,
you have done,
and done beautifully.
-You, uh...
-(cheering, applause)
You gave voice... you gave voice
to-to underserved voices
in the media arena,
and you did it...
It was a show that was raw
and poignant and funny and smart
-and all of those things. -Thank
you. -(cheering, applause)
And... you did it from scratch.
And what-what you
and Rory and Robin
and your
tremendous collaborators
and Dre in the booth and...
You took something
and got better
-every (bleep) day.
-Oh, man.
-(cheering) -That's so nice.
Thanks, Jon. -Every one.
Thank you.
And I think that, uh...
Uh, we talked about
a little thing called...
uh, I guess the word
s-some would use is "resonance."
Did you resonate
with-with an audience?
I would say not-not only that
but in an important way,
but in a way
that you don't even realize yet
and won't reveal itself
-for years to come,
and it's this: -Mm-hmm.
you started a conversation
that was not on television
when you began.
And you worked with a group
of people
who you invited
to that conversation
to collaborate with you,
to sharpen that conversation.
And what you don't realize is,
you walk out of this room
and that conversation
doesn't end.
And all the people
that you work with
are gonna take
what they learned here
and what they learned from you
and the beautiful experience
that they had,
and you're gonna start
to see them doing things
in the business as well
and taking that
and taking other experiences
and you're gonna watch that
flourish.
And that's gonna have you on it.
-Well, thank you so much, Jon.
That's very kind. -And your DNA.
And-and that's
a beautiful thing.
And so, in closing,
-Yes.
-I want to say to you this:
you did it, my...
-Jon. No, no.
-Wait. My...
-No, Jon. No, you can't say...
-You did it, my...
-No, you can't... you can't say
the... -my-my mishpocha.
-What?
-Yeah. That's nice.
That works. That works.
-I love you, man. -Jon Stewart!
Thank you. I love you, too.
-You did a great job.
-Thank you so much.
-Really great job.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much, Jon.
-Great. Thank you.
-Oh, man. -Thank you.
-(cheering and applause)